lo que haremos en este vídeo será
practicar un poco derivadas usando la
regla de la potencia primero vamos a
hacer la derivada con respecto a x de 1
/ x cuál es su derivada pausa el vídeo e
inténtalo
bueno tal vez en un principio digas cómo
es que puedo aplicar aquí la regla de la
potencia para recordar la regla de la
potencia nos dice que si hacemos la
derivada de x elevado a la n con
respecto a x
esto será igual a traer el exponente al
frente multiplicando la expresión esto
ya lo hemos probado anteriormente en
otros vídeos n por equis elevado y ahora
nos quedará como potencia
1 - que la potencia anterior es decir n
1 pero tal vez me digas que en este
ejercicio no podemos aplicar esta regla
sin embargo la clave es apreciar que uno
entre x es lo mismo que tener x elevado
a la menos 1 entonces esto será la
derivada con respecto a x de x elevado a
la menos 1 y ahora si ya se parece más a
la regla que queremos utilizar por lo
tanto esto será igual a amd tomamos
nuestro exponente original lo llevamos
al frente menos 1 por x elevado a la
menos 1 - 1
y esto será igual a menos x elevado a la
menos 2 y ya está listo hagamos otro
ejemplo imagina que nos dicen que fx es
igual a la raíz cúbica de x y queremos
encontrar a efe prima de x pausa el
vídeo y ver si puedes encontrar de nuevo
la respuesta una vez más tal vez puedas
pensar en cómo puedo hacer la derivada
de algo así más aún cuando estamos
pensando que la regla de la potencia
podría servirnos y bueno la idea detrás
es reescribir esto como un exponente
puedes reescribir la raíz cúbica como x
elevado a la un tercio si hacemos la
derivada entonces tendremos que poner
este un tercio al frente y me queda un
tercio que multiplica a x elevado a la
un tercio menos uno y esto será igual a
un tercio que multiplica a x y cuántos
un tercio menos uno bueno es menos dos
tercios y ya lo tenemos con
tenemos resuelto el segundo ejercicio
espero que todos estos ejemplos te
ayuden a ver el poderoso alcance de la
regla de la potencia con ella podemos
abordar un rango mucho más amplio de
derivadas de las que en un inicio
pensábamos bien hagamos otro ejemplo y
voy a hacer esto un poquito más
peliagudo imagina que queremos encontrar
la derivada con respecto a x de la raíz
cúbica de x cuadrada cuál será nuestra
derivada es más no solamente nos
preguntaremos por la derivada pensemos
también en la derivada evaluada en x
igual a 8 pausa el vídeo e intenta
encontrar la solución viene primero
encontremos la derivada y después
evaluaremos en x igual a 8
y la clave aquí es recordar que podemos
escribir esto justo como lo hicimos acá
arriba como la derivada con respecto a x
de y en lugar de poner la raíz cúbica de
x cuadrada diremos que esto es x
cuadrada elevado a la un tercio
qué es lo mismo que la derivada con
respecto a x de ahora bien si tengo algo
evaluado a un cierto exponente y eso
elevado a otro exponente eso es lo mismo
que tomarme el producto de los
exponentes entonces tendría x elevado a
la amm y me quedan dos por un tercio que
es lo mismo que dos tercios y esto sería
igual a si ahora aplicamos la derivada
traemos este dos tercios al frente me
queda dos tercios de x elevado a la dos
tercios menos uno pero cuánto es dos
tercios menos uno bueno dos tercios
menos tres tercios
es lo mismo que menos un tercio y si
ahora queremos saber qué pasa en x igual
a 8 entonces evaluamos tengo dos tercios
que multiplican a x pero x en este caso
es igual a 8 y esto elevado a la menos 1
ahora bien en cuanto es 8 elevado a la
un tercio bueno 8 elevado a la un tercio
es 2 por lo tanto esto es lo mismo que 8
elevado a la menos un tercio lo cual es
un medio es más déjame hacerlo paso por
paso para que te quede más claro podemos
escribir esto como dos tercios que
multiplica a uno entre ocho elevado a la
un tercio y bueno estoy acá es
simplemente un medio y después tengo dos
tercios por un medio y eso es lo mismo
que bueno podemos cancelar el 2 y me
queda simplemente un tercio y hemos
terminado nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo